>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
PEOPLE HAVEN'T BEEN TRAVELING
MUCH, THEY'VE BEEN STUCK AT
HOME.
IF YOU HAD A CHANCE TO VISIT
NEW YORK CITY RECENTLY -- IF YOU
HAVE, YOU KNOW THE TRUTH.
IT'S AWFUL.
AWFUL, AND IN A VERY
RECOGNIZABLE WAY.
IN NEW YORK LOOKS LIKE IN
NEW YORK IN THE 1970s WITHOUT
STUDIO 54.
THE CITY HAS ONCE AGAIN BECOME
DIRTY CHAOTIC AND DANGEROUS --
JUST AS IN THE 1970s, A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN NEW YORK ARE
FEELING.
MAYBE YOU'RE WATCHING THE SHOW
RIGHT NOW MASK LISTS FROM YOUR
PATIO IN FORT LAUDERDALE, GLASS
OF WINE IN HAND THINKING TO
YOURSELF, WHY SHOULD I CARE
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS IN NEW YORK?
I VOTED TO GET OUT OF THAT
PLACE.
LET IT ROT.
THAT'S A FAIR POINT.
CONSIDER ANOTHER PERSPECTIVE.
IT NEW YORK IS THE BIGGEST CITY
IN THE UNITED STATES, MORE THAN
8 MILLION PEOPLE LIVE THERE
INCLUDING AMERICANS.
WHAT HAPPENS IN NEW YORK AFFECTS
ALL OF US.
IN THE END, WE HAVE TO PAY FOR
THE BENCH ANYWAY.
WE MIGHT AS WELL ROUTE FOR THE
BEST OUTCOME.
TONIGHT, BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
SOMETHING GOOD MIGHT BE
HAPPENING IN NEW YORK CITY, IN
FACT, SOMETHING GOOD IS
HAPPENING.
BILL de BLASIO IS HEADING FOR
RETIREMENT.
WE KNOW THAT FOR SURE.
THE SINGLE WORST MAYOR IN THE
HISTORY OF REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT HAS REACHED THE END
OF HIS SECOND DISASTROUS TERM.
THE LONG MUNICIPAL NIGHTMARE IS
OVER.
de BLASIO WAS LEAVING.
THE QUESTION IS, WHO REPLACES
HIM?
UNTIL RECENTLY WE ASSUMED THAT
WOULD BE ANDREW YANG, A GUY WHO
IS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
WE TALKED TO HIM AS HE RAN, AND
FOUND THAT UNLIKE A LOT OF 20/20
DEMOCRATS, BETO O'ROURKE --
LOOKING AT YOU.
ANDREW YANG IS NOT STUPID, HE'S
LEGITIMATE SMART, AT TIMES
INSIGHTFUL AND WILLING TO TALK
ABOUT INTERESTING IDEAS IN
PUBLIC.
UNFORTUNATELY, IN THE END, THE
WEIGHT OF ANDREW YANG'S LIFE
CONTRITE AND CHILLS, PULLED HIM
BACK TO THE POISONOUS CULTURE
THAT PRODUCED THEM IN THE FIRST
PLACE, AND HE EMBRACED
INEVITABLY THE DUMBEST KIND OF .
AT THIS POINT, THE ONLY REAL
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ANDREW YANG
AND THEN THE NEXT UNHAPPY LADY
BROWSING WHOLE FOODS IS
ANDREW YANG IS SLIGHTLY MORE
ARTICULATE, THAT'S ODD, AND
BITES THE DUST.
WE WERE WRONG.
HE MAY NOT WIN.
TURNS OUT, NEW YORK IS CHANGING.
ALL OF THE URBAN DECAY APPEARS
TO HAVE AWAKENED TO VOTERS
ACTUAL ISSUES.
ACCORDING TO A NEW POLL,
ANDREW YANG IS LOSING TO A GUY
CALLED ERIC ADAMS, THE BROOKLYN
BOROUGH PRESIDENT, CONTROVERSIAL
FOR MANY YEARS.
IN A LOT OF WAYS, ERICA ADAMS IS
A CONVENTIONAL BIG-CITY
DEMOCRAT, INTO IDENTITY
POLITICS, TOO.
THE DIFFERENCES ERICA ADAMS IS
ECCENTRIC ENOUGH TO SAY WHAT HE
REALLY THINKS ONCE IN A WHILE.
FOR EXAMPLE, AND HIS SPEECH LAST
YEAR ADAMS LAUNCHED INTO AN
ATTACK ON THE LIBERALS WHO HAVE
FLOODED INTO NEW YORK OVER THE
PAST THREE DECADES.
YOU'RE JUST AN AUDIENCE OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO LIVE WITH
THEM.
QUOTE, YOU WERE HERE BEFORE
STARBUCKS, BEFORE OTHERS CAME.
FOLKS ARE NOT ONLY HIGH JAEDEN G
YOUR APARTMENTS, BUT SAVE THE
THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO YOU
ARE NO LONGER IMPORTANT.
WHAT WAS ERICA ADAMS TALKING
ABOUT?
WHAT ARE THE IMPORTANT THINGS
THAT SMOKE FUSSY LIBERALS DON'T
WANT TO TO TALK ABOUT?
CRIME AND DISORDER MOSTLY, THOSE
MATTER.
ONCE YOU'RE AFRAID OF GETTING
SHOT TO DEATH WHILE WALKING TO
THE STORE, NOTHING ELSE REALLY
MATTERS.
NO MATTER WHAT COLOR YOU ARE,
CRIME AND DISORDER RUGER LIFE.
WHATEVER ELSE HE IS, ERIC ADAMS
IS ABLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
HE SPENT 20 YEARS AS A COP IN
NEW YORK.
>> WE ARE FACING A CRISIS UNLIKE
ANYTHING WE'VE EVER SEEN BEFORE.
BUSINESSES ARE CLOSING, CRIME IS
RISING, HOMELESSNESS IS SOARING,
AND OUR FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING.
WE CAN'T HAVE AN EDUCATION
SYSTEM THAT FAILS TO PUT OUR
CHILDREN ON A PATHWAY OF FIXED
SUCCESS AND LEAVE THEM AT A DEAD
END OF EIGHT CRIME AND
HOPELESSNESS.
>> Tucker: BUSINESSES ARE
CLOSING, CRIMES ARE RISING,
HOMELESSNESS IS SOARING.
ADAMS SAID THAT OUT LOUD.
BY ITSELF, THAT'S A VICTORY OF
NEW YORK POLITICS, REALITY OVER
DILUTION.
IF THERE'S BEEN A RIGID CODE
AMONG THOSE SMOG FUSSY LIBERALS
IN NEW YORK CITY THAT YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO NOTICE AS THINGS FALL
APART.
IF IF YOU DO NOTICE, YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO THINK IT'S CHARMING
OR DIVERSE OR SOMEHOW RELATED TO
EQUITY.
MORE DRUG ODs AND PEN STATION,
HOW VIBRANT SPIRITED BEFORE
DEATH DOESN'T THINK THAT WAY AT
ALL.
HE THINKS IT'S AWFUL.
THERE'S A SOLUTION, DON'T PUT UP
WITH THAT MAKE NEW YORK CITY
SAFE AGAIN, EVERYTHING DEPENDS
ON IT.
>> IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY
CONSOLATION IF A POLICE OFFICER
SHOOT SOMEONE ILLEGALLY OR IF A
GANG BANGER AND BLUE JEANS.
NO MATTER WHAT COMMUNITY, PEOPLE
WANT THEIR FAMILIES TO BE SAFE.
THAT RESONATES WITH EVERY DAY
YOU NEW YORKERS.
I KNOW MY MESSAGE WILL RESONATE
WITH THEM.
COMPANIES ARE NOT COMING TO
NEW YORK, OUR TOURISM INDUSTRY
IS NOT GOING TO RETURN IF
TOURISTS ARE SHOT GRAND CENTRAL
STATION.
THE FIRST OF BUSINESS IS TO GET
IT UNDER CONTROL.
>> Tucker: THE FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS TO GET VIOLENCE
UNDER CONTROL.
HE WOULD THINK THAT WOULD BE THE
TOP PRIORITY.
WHY HAVE A MAYOR OR OTHERWISE?
IT'S NOT THERE TOP PRIORITY.
EVEN AS HE POLLUTES THE
ATMOSPHERE WITH HIS WEED SMOKE.
ERIC ADAMS IS ACTUALLY SERIOUS
ABOUT FIGHTING CRIME.
IF HE BECOMES MAYOR, HE PLANS TO
CARRY HIS OWN GUN.
HE WOULD SHOOT HIMSELF BY
ACCIDENT.
>> WOULD YOU CARRY A FIREARM ON
YOU?
>> I WILL.
AND NUMBER TWO, I WON'T HAVE A
SECURITY DETAIL, CHILDREN HAVE A
SECURITY DETAIL.
NUMBER THREE, THE HYPOCRISY OF
THOSE WHO HAVE CITYWIDE
OFFICIALS THAT SAID, YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE GUNS IN CHURCH.
OF THOSE GUYS WALKING WITH THEM,
THEY'VE GOT GUNS.
>> Tucker: YOU CAN TELL HOW
TRUE SOMETHING IS BY HOW THE
USUAL HYSTERICS RESPOND TO IT.
IN THIS CASE, THEY WERE
HORRIFIED HOW COULD YOU?
ERICA ADAMS LATER SAYS HE
MIGHT'VE BEEN JOKING.
AS YOU JUST SAW, HE WASN'T
JOKING.
HE OBVIOUSLY MEANT THAT.
NORMAL VOTERS APPRECIATED IT.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY?
MEANWHILE, ONCE PROMISING
ANDREW YANG HAS DESCENDED DEEPER
INTO THE SELF DISCREDITING
ABSURDITY OF MODERN IDENTITY
POLITICS, SOMETHING TURNS OUT
MOST VOTERS DON'T LIKE.
WHO KNEW?
YANG WAS ASKED ABOUT VIOLENCE
AGAINST ASIAN-AMERICANS, EVERY
SINGLE HUMAN BEING UNDERSTANDS
WHERE THAT VIOLENCE COME FROM,
BUT YANG DID NOT SAY THAT.
HIS SOLUTION?
GIVE MORE TAXPAYER MONEY TO
RACIAL AFFINITY GROUPS ALIGNED
WITH THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THAT WILL MAKE ASIAN GRANDMOTHER
SAFE.
EXCEPT IT WON'T MAKE ASIAN
GRANDMOTHERS OR ANYONE ELSE
SAFE, BECAUSE WE TRIED IT, IT
DOESN'T WORK.
ALL THAT DOES WORK IS ENFORCING
THE LAW, AND MOST PEOPLE KNOW
THAT.
YES, ENFORCING THE LAW IS THE
ONE THING ANDREW YANG OPPOSES.
YANG HAS CALLED FOR TAKING MORE
MONEY FROM THE NYPD BUDGET AND
GIVING IT TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES, WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
IN A RADIO INTERVIEW, GANGS
SUGGEST DEFUNDING THE POLICE BY
$1 BILLION, WHICH THEY'VE DONE,
MAY NOT BE ENOUGH.
>> THEY DID SHIFT $1 BILLION
FROM THE NYPD.
THEY SHIFTED IT TO OTHER THINGS,
WOULD YOU DO MORE THAN THAT?
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO
BE LOOKING AT.
IF WERE GOING TO LOOK AT THE
CITY BUDGET, THE NYPD IS MOST
LIKELY PLACE TO LOOK BECAUSE
WERE DEFENDING A LOT OF MONEY ON
THE NYPD.
>> Tucker: THE SAD THING IS,
PEOPLE LIKE ANDREW YANG, EXETER
BROWN COLUMBIA ARE SUCH CRAVEN
KISSER'S, THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE ADVANTAGE IN TELLING THE
TRUTH.
IF HE SAID, ARE YOU JOKING?
IT DEFUND THE POLICE?
THAT'S INSANE.
THEY PROBABLY WOULD'VE AGREED.
HE TRIED TO SUCK UP AND
HUMILIATED HIMSELF.
HE WENT ON FROM THERE, THE
POLICE SHOULD LEARN MARTIAL ARTS
SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO USE THEIR
WEAPONS, JUST WELL-PLACED KARATE
CHOPS.
THEY'VE ALSO CALLED FOR CHANGING
THE UNIFORMS AND TITLES AND
POLICE DEPARTMENT'S ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
I MIGHT RENAME THEM GUARDIANS
AND ADOPT A DIFFERENT COLOR
SCHEME.
YOU GOT TO WONDER, IF THERE'S
STILL A CONCERN SHE WOULD SEE
FOR THINGS THAT ARE STUPID.
GRAD SCHOOL LIBERALS LOVE THIS
STUFF.
IT FAWNING OVER CRIMINALS MAKES
THEM FEEL GOOD ABOUT THEMSELVES,
AND WHEN THINGS DISINTEGRATE AS
WELL, AND THEY JUST LEAVE.
THEY LITERALLY HAD FOR THE
HILLS, ANYWHERE WITHOUT THE
"CRIME PROBLEM."
IF A LOT OF THEM ARE DOING THAT
NOW.
AT THE LIBERALS WHO STILL REMAIN
IN NEW YORK DON'T HAVE MUCH USE
FOR ERICA ADAMS, WHERE LEE IS
THE ONE BLACK CANDIDATE THEY
DON'T LIKE.
YOU GET THE FEELING HE DOESN'T
LIKE THEM BACK.
HE DEFINITELY DOESN'T BELIEVE
THEM WHEN THEY TALK.
HERE IS ERIC ADAMS AND THE RADIO
ON JULY SYMPATHIZE AND WITH ALL
PEOPLE, DONALD TRUMP.
>> WERE IN THE PERIOD OF
HEADLINES.
THE TRUTH BE, NOBODY CARES ABOUT
TRUTH ANYMORE.
THIS IS AN INSTAGRAM, TWITTER
UNIVERSE WHERE PEOPLE SAY,
LISTEN, WE DO CELLS
THAT'S -- PLEASE.
MODERATE THINKING,
COMMUNICATION, REAL FACTS THAT
DON'T EVEN MATTER IN THIS
UNIVERSAL AND RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: COULD IT BE THE
THING I FALLEN APART TO SUCH AN
EXTENT, GOTTEN SO CRAZY THAT
SOMEONE LIKE ERICA ADAMS, WHO
YOU WOULD'VE LEFT OFF THE STAGE
18 MONTHS AGO AS CRAZY HIMSELF
ACTUALLY IS THE SANEST GUY
RUNNING, AND THE O